hello everyone and welcome to round two
of the grand KHS classic here we have a
game between Magnus Carlsen and holy fun
now I only have one photo from this
round for now this is a photo called a
cross in here playing against holy fun
making his first move and it was sent to
me by a subscriber he contacted me over
Instagram his name is Enzo Kaiser he
says he's at the Greinke chess classic
at the moment and that he can provide
samples from every round so I'm very
very happy he sent it to me and maybe I
will get some official photos I probably
will I will include them in in a video
from I'll probably make more videos from
round 2 as there were a lot of
interesting games so I will I will
include it in there so let's see this
game I did prepare there are a lifetime
record also I will show you for this
game but I will show I will show to
after the game so let's see it if an
already played a game against Anand she
drew a game with the black pieces now
again she has black pieces against
Magnus Carlsen so I mean that's that's
what that's what you came for
a bit unfortunate but Carlson will also
have 5 games with the black pieces and
only 4 games with the white pieces I
mean there are 9 rounds it can can't be
even so Carlsen opens with E 4 E 5 and
the Bishop to c4 he goes for his Bishop
opening nice to have 6 d 3 C 6 Queen 2 e
2 and Bishop to e7 nice to f3 d6 c3
Knight B to d7 and Bishop it back to b3
you wanna bring it to b3 I don't want to
allow any expansion which tempo would be
5 and a 5 and also a black could at some
point push d5 and then white would be
force to react as the bishop would be on
c4 so Bishop to b3 always a useful move
we have castles castles and a5 now D for
a for attacking the bishop the bishop to
c2 and rook to e8 making room for the
bishop to come to f8 then even will push
g6 and try and play the Bishop to g7
rook to e1 and now Bishop to f8 Queen to
d1 and
b5 now night B - D - Quinta C 7/9 - f1
g6 and Bishop to g5 Bishop to e3 I guess
is also possible with the idea of Queen
to d2 followed by Bishop to h6
but if like goes Knight to g4 then again
you have to move the bishop and then
life can even push pull the bishop back
for example Bishop to d2 and it would be
it would be pretty much the same
position that happened in the game only
now you have the knight on g4 instead on
f6 as there has happened in the game
which is better hard to say but probably
probably immediately Bishop to g5 is
better as cause and decided to play this
so h6 and Bishop to D - we have Bishop
to g7 and now Knight the g3 nice to be 6
and now b3 a capture some b3 a capture
some b3 rook captures and I want Queen
captures on a1 and now Bishop to g4 and
here it is Queen to c1 and now Carson
has this Queen Bishop battery attacking
that h6 pawn and here you could play
something like King to h7 but then Dan
Carlson will start his attack with knife
to h4 probably followed by Knight to a5
as this would be a very dangerous night
sacrifice so if and immediately captures
that Bishop captures on f3 g captures on
f3 and here we have H 5 H 5
I've seen the interview after the game
Carlsen didn't really agree with this
move
probably King to h7 was better and after
f4 of course and said he didn't really
he didn't really know what he wanted
here but you know he would just play and
see what happens but okay after G
capture Sonic and if an f3 h5
Bishop to h6 and here Queen to e7 Queen
to e7 is a move designed to protected
the knight on f6
but you you you'll understand why
because if black would play something
like c5 then after D captures and Bishop
captures on h6 Queen captures and rook
captures
why to go for this Knight to a5 idea and
now of course if you captured an Queen
to g5 check King moves and Queen
captures on f6 so this was the idea
protecting the knight on f6 and after F
captures Bishop captures and a lot of
attacking ideas here for White Queen can
come to h8 to h6 at this rook can come
to the a file and then harass black from
from the Queen side so definitely
wouldn't be a very pleasant position for
black so here even goes Queen to e7 and
now Bishop captures on g7 Carson also
considered playing something like King
to h1 but then after after this h4 move
and then you would you you could get
Knight to f5 but he decided he didn't
want to go for this this would be okay
for white but like it doesn't have to
play h4 here so he quickly decided he
he's not gonna do this so he decided
Bishop captures on g7 King captors on g7
and now Queen to g5 of course with the
very serious threat of Knight to f5
check the ponies of course pinned black
will lose the Queen and the game so King
to h7 now comes f4 and quickly night
after d7 - wants to exchange Queens
across and of course doesn't mind Queen
captures rook captures and now a pawn
captures on e5 d captures on e5 and here
cross and plays a move that he says he
was extremely happy to make and Peter
like Oh praised him for it he says it's
it's quite a brilliant move you know I
really a subtle a subtle brilliancy
because most most people probably go
rook to e1 and then after he captures on
d4 black would get the decent counter
play would see with c5 exchange the
pawns in the center probably an easy
game to draw for black but here Carlsen
played rook to d1 and it's obviously
it's very difficult to understand why
this is such a strong move because it's
it's extremely hard to find a move for
black here even played
rook to e8 and Carson thinks that this
rook to e8
might have might have been not such a
great idea but it's again very hard to
find a move for black here
although simply exchanging and going
with the same idea black could have
played if the rope was on a one does it
doesn't seem all that bad for black but
okay rook to e8 like we said and now D
captures on e5 Knight captures on e5 and
f4 and now you see the problem you do
have to do something with this Knight if
you if you go back then you have Knights
protecting each other and that's never a
great idea you can't move this night
because this Knight is hanging and this
Knight doesn't really have anywhere to
go here after white pushes a 5 then this
night is coming to e4 and from there he
will be a monster night controlling all
of the central squares so after f4 night
the g4 was played and now rook to d6 and
here even played rook to e6 and here
again in an interview after the game
Peter like have suggested that rook to
e8 was actually a better idea for black
that kind of kind of forces a draw
because after rook captures and c6 you
have looked way to attacking the bishop
bishop moves now Knight captures on h2
and after you grab the piece then Knight
to f3 is check and now it's a perpetual
if you're joking each one of course this
would be checkmate and if you don't if
you go for example to f1 then it would
be a perpetual check simply night h2
checking moves Knight f3 checking moves
in the night h2 if you go if you try to
run to the Queen side then you would
actually lose the game because after
check you lose the bishop here and after
you black plays this h4 move now it's
winning because the H pawn is simply too
powerful you have to move the knight and
then after captures and rope to d3 there
is no stopping the pawn you would have
to sacrifice this night for the pawn and
then black would easily win so that was
one idea
like who gave after the game but okay
rook to e6 by - rook to d8 now King to
g7 and now Knight to f1 and here rook to
f6
instead of rook to f6 Knight to f6 would
have been better with a double attack on
this pawn and after a night to d2
defending it the game goes on here rook
to f6 was played by - and here h3 and
this was Carson's idea ninety-two h6 and
now f5g captures an f5 ninth to g3
threatening Knight captures on h5 with a
check and the fork on the rook so you do
have to play something here here even
played rock to g6 pinning the night but
better yet was something caused and
suggested after the game after after
this move and king - f2 here even played
F captures on e4 but Carson said after
the game that if she played rook to g5
it's it's very unlikely that there's any
progress that Carson could make simply a
simply great move defends everything h4
is coming so he he didn't know know what
to do here but she played F captures on
e4 and here across and said that here he
definitely felt that he had a winning
game so Knight captures on h5 with check
King h7 and now Bishop captures on e4 f5
only move if you don't want to lose the
exchange and here Bishop to g2 and the
game Carson says Bishop to g2 is an
extremely important move because you do
want to move the bishop to a nice square
you don't want to move it to a square
like f3 because you will still win a
pawn but for example night to have 7
rope to f8 Knight to e5 now you have to
grab the pawn but then black will
eliminate the bishop and the bishop is
an extremely powerful piece in a
position like this rook captures and you
you would be a performant but it's hard
to say now if you could actually win
this game so that's why Carson says
Bishop to g2 here a very important move
so night to f7 there's really no better
move to play
are there other than this you could go
something like like c5 but after rook to
b8 again it's the position is so
difficult for black can't really move
anything so hard to find the move so
here even tried a knight to have seven
she has to activate her pieces roof to
f8 by Carlson and now Knight to e5 and
here first attacked the rook rook moves
and now rook captures an f5 so Carson
wanna pawn here and he managed to keep
his strong lights were Bishop Knight B
to d7 King to e2
King to g 7h for now 90 to f7 bishop to
d4 Knight comes to defy a five-night to
h5 check King h6 night to g3 and now
rook to e6 and here King to e3 rook to
h5 seems like seems like a scary idea
with the bishop slicing here but after
King comes to f8 there's no no point in
doing this white it doesn't really have
anything
so after rookie six King III King g7 now
rook F one King to f8 Knight to f5 and
here we have Knight to g4 check king f4
Knight to f6 Bishop to f3 Knight to d5
check Bishop captures pawn captures and
here rook to a1 now Carlson will bring
his rook all the way either to a 7 or 8
depending on what even plays and then
from the back rank he will target the
weak points here on b5 and nd5 King to
g8 now rook comes to a twitch check King
h7 rock to a7 painting the knight rope
to f6 defending h5 King to g8 rock to d7
and here even played before and C
capture some before was played and in
this position
- resigned the game although she might
not have resigned but ok I think she did
resign but she was also very long very
long clock so also one thing calls and
said after the game that that's it's a
useful thing to play fast then you have
more time
in critical moments so so what a
brilliant idea
and yeah before I forget I said I will
show you the there are a lifetime record
so here it is this is their lifetime
record in classical games two of them
played six times and Carson won five
games and they drew one game so even
never defeated Magnus Carlsen and I
believe that's only classical and
including rapid and exhibition as you
can see it's a result six to zero for
Coulson so other than that they also
played a rapid or an exhibition game it
doesn't really say here so yeah I'm
definitely a nice a nice record for
Carlsen and now we'll see how the
tournament goes for even she now kind of
did did the worst part she faced Anand
and and Carlsen with the black pieces so
now she will get some opportunities with
the white pieces as well so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said do check out all the content from
Greinke chess classic you will have all
the interviews under YouTube channel I
believe they will make like trailer if
you've seen the trailer from round one
they will make a trailer for every round
so do check it out I will put it all in
the description below I just don't have
it yet and they didn't release the
interviews yet but as soon as they do I
will edit in the description so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check through my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting game thank you all